thanks sakamoto-san hello everyone
welcome to nintendo treehouse live
i am super excited about this next
segment where we're going to
delve into an early work in progress
version of metroid red
show some of samus's new moves in action
and also
i think get to a little bit of the way
the game develops this
uh suspense and tension that um gives
the game its title
so i'm joined by audrey and teresa from
nintendo treehouse
and teresa is going to take us into the
depths of planet zdr yeah
all right so let's uh take a deep dive
into
uh the very beginning of the game um so
we're gonna backtrack just a little bit
to show
samus's free movement here
um so like i just
spent a little few missiles so i'm gonna
use this uh
interactive here to replenish um but
one of the things i want to show here is
uh free aim which
for those that have played uh metroid
samus returns this has
made a comeback and you can see
a lot of the the area around as you use
it
um also has this little tracking system
that
when it's targeting an enemy it'll make
that sound
i want to take a moment to say that as
nate and sakamoto-san already mentioned
this is the first new 2d metroid game in
19
years that's almost two decades i don't
know if you did the math
but uh that's a lot of years we've been
waiting for this for a long time so
we're we're really excited to be finally
showing this to everyone
here's another returning move from
metroid samus returns which is the
melee counter
one of my favorite um features um and
then
a new one is or the development of the
melee counter
let that guy move a little bit back
come back the
melee dash i really love that because it
doesn't break momentum i can immediately
do
a counter and immediate damage to an
enemy
yeah something this game does really
well is improve upon the improvements
from metroid samus returns so like you
mentioned we had free aim and
the melee counter in that game and here
we have the running the running free aim
which gives you even more freedom
and the dash melee so instead of having
to stand still
uh still and wait for enemies to attack
you you can just go get them
which uh really uh has great movements
to this game
yeah i i love that like samus
moves so well and it's just all that
freedom it's just this is
probably the smoothest i've been able to
control samus in a really long time
absolutely and you've opened up the map
screen here something that
metroid fans know to love and adore
the map system is just as important in
this game as ever
and it really shows you uh the classic
metroid game gameplay progression which
is back in full force in this game where
you look at your map you identify areas
that you haven't been to yet or
aren't able to access yet you try and
find another way through find a new
ability
push your way forward fill in the map
latherance repeat so
that's back and better than ever in my
opinion
yeah and this area here is blinking
white because there is a
something here that i haven't discovered
yet so i could use markers to kind of
pinpoint it just in case i don't have an
ability
i'm going to have to backtrack here once
i'm able to explore it
don't sleep on those markers those can
be really important in this labyrinthine
world
sure um but this looks curious
it is really uh a part of the charm of
metroid though having this uh
renewed uh sense of purpose in your
backtracking paired with pushing forward
yeah one another thing i want to
pinpoint is the amount of work the dev
team put in in
samus's animations like just her
animation of
gripping the walls when she can't move
or like holding onto the ledge
it's just looking around yeah you'll
notice
little touches everywhere so keep an eye
out for them
that seamless transition to these sort
of uh story scenes is great
little moments like this when you're in
helmet view for a moment really add to
the isolation
uh and the tone of this game yeah now
this game is a
sequel to uh metroid fusion but you can
see that her suit looks a little bit
different than that so
um that'll be a story element that
people find out what happened uh when
they play the game
we don't want to spoil too much
so these are the emmy that sakamoto-san
was talking about and none of samus's
weapons seem to
do anything against them so
run yep oh that slide move is so cool
she looks so cool when she's lighting
yep it is
nope okay no just just no yeah
oh gosh uh missiles don't work either
oh my gosh so scary about this being
called dread
that would be why they're very
relentless oh my oh
wow okay
did a little reach for me there
that was new oh yeah that one's clearly
not well but it's still
quite frightening yeah um i'm glad that
it's a bit damaged and can't completely
reach to me but we're gonna have to find
a different way to tackle that enemy
you know this thing is a central unit
which controls
various areas of the planet it's sort of
a
bio-mechanical computer kind of a homage
to
maybe similar units in previous metroid
games and
from this unit samus can power up uh get
a temporary power up
for her um arm cannon and turn it into
the omega cannon
yeah so in typical 2d metroid fashion
we've always seen the camera panned
around here and
now with the omega cannon ability
there's this dynamic camera that you get
to see
over samus's shoulder which is so so
cool
yeah little additions like that really
flesh out the classic
2d gameplay without it feeling like it
strays too far from what we loved about
it
just makes it seem really powerful let's
see if this works against our
emmy friend here
it takes a little while to charge up so
it does way too long
okay oh i wanted to make sure i had it
on
the site i hope you enjoyed that that's
your one shot at it
yes it was so powerful that in order to
take that emmy
down um our we lose the ability of the
omega cannon
and it goes back to a regular arm cannon
it was worth it though we can breathe
easy now
it was for a moment
[Music]
i also want to point out while you're
scrolling your way through all of these
different halls there are so many
different ways to play this game
like teresa is amazing with a missile
she's the queen of the missiles but
you can also just shoot your regular arm
cannon
you can try and avoid enemies altogether
try and hit them all
really it's up to you what kind of samus
you want to be
yeah and as as
audrey pointed out to earlier that you
could use
free aim to do more like line of sight
shooting but you could also just frame
shoot while you're moving as well
it's good because you need to shoot a
lot of different things in this game
[Laughter]
i want to see a pixelated door and now
i'm filled with dread
this is a new entryway um
yep these are the entries to the various
zones that the emmy are patrolling
and uh once you're in there you need to
be on the lookout for those
yeah you can hear in the background the
music is
so atmospheric it really puts you on
pins and needles just listening to it
very i am completely on edge because
yeah
really eerie i can't seem to climb these
yet
not yet yeah it's the detail in the
background
and things is great yeah and there he is
there it is
especially during moments like this you
can really appreciate how
cool it is to have an hd uh 2d metroid
game
we we tried that already okay it was
worth a shot
just try again maybe we'll work on this
one now run
so luckily this emmy can't go through
tight spaces
so i have an advantage here somehow
emily doesn't seem
oh worried
oh okay oh it's fast oh you're following
me
okay you gotta you gotta get away from
that that's my recommendation
yeah when they go into this uh patrol
mode and turn
red um the door locks until they sort of
lose track of you
it's still trying to get at her
try find another way to get to me yeah
also i don't know if it's my
heart throbbing through my hands or the
controller
but it's yeah it's pretty nerve-wracking
when facing the emmy they're
terrifying species yeah team makes it
seem like she's calm cool collected and
badass i like to pretend that she's
actually as nervous as i am when i play
it but i don't think it's true
i do want to point out like also the
backgrounds like the amount of detail
that the developer
the development team has put into like
not just the
enemies in the forefront but also in the
background i don't know if you guys can
tell the shimmering
thing in there there it's moving it's
okay that
doesn't bode well yeah well probably
note that for the future yeah some of
those details kind of tell the story as
effectively as you know
a voice over or anything yeah if you
want to be a bounty hunter you have to
pay attention to details
and watch out for gooey enemies
this is more but i love the detail of
like the the rib cage
in the background you just know
something went down there
so uh the thing about metroid enemies
too is that some of them have patterns
and
and you can counter them um and others
don't like this one
so i'm just gonna blast them move him
out of the way
so i can use it um and this room is a
communication room
with adam who happens to be
samus's ship's pc or a computer
we're going to skip this part here just
because we don't want to spoil any of
the lore but
dan if you could summarize for the folks
at home yeah so as samus is
exploring uh she uploads data to adam
say ai and adam kind of gives
a little analysis um just just really
hints though not
necessarily telling you where to go or
anything like that it's still up to you
to kind of explore but
there's some interesting lore in there
and um
you know some some little hints that you
can potentially use
and um in that one adam was basically
summarizing
the uh the emmy and kind of the limits
that they have of patrolling a zone
and um also how dangerous they are which
we we've kind of
seen but hopefully we won't see too much
first hand here
also you can see t doing a great job of
just shooting at the environment looking
for secrets looking for a way forward
because it's not always going to be
obvious you really have to
it's like a puzzle it's not just action
it's not just exploration
there's also a lot of puzzle elements
here trying to find the way forward
yeah and it's really cool too how
metroid dread
does this really sweet balance of you
know
the moments where you're allowed to have
like some quiet to
solve the puzzles and then it's
interspersed with this
really heavy intense action so here's
the uh
oh nope
um that was uh the emmy as dan had
mentioned
they have kind of three modes one is the
surveillance the others uh
which is uh marked with blue they're
just scanning the area
um so excited i'm like
playing the name of chase so fast with
it
um and then when it has
samus on i uh eyesight uh it turns red
which is the
um chase okay
so yellow is it's heard it's heard a
noise or
sense the vibration and it's going to go
investigate that
oh oh oh gosh no
no so
the emmy uh are pretty
relentless and ruthless uh it is sort of
like a perma-death which is
very unusual um for you know enemies
with uh
in the metroid series but luckily it's
not very
it's the game's pretty forgiving uh it
allows you to
respawn at an area that you were in
recently so
we're able to just go back and
counter that again yes he said insta
kill is new to the series
but uh it's really great because it
offers a chance for you to have that
challenging difficulty that i think
metroid fans expect
but without being quite so punishing
with the respawning that
you just have to play the whole game to
get back to where you are so it's a
really
wonderful balance yeah and when
the emmy are in patrol mode which is
that uh
right now it's in pursuit of me um
they're scanning areas where they last
sense movement
and so they'll go and investigate it
and then if they see something in
eyesight then they'll go chase it
this is such a small but really neat
touch the way that samus moves
slower in the water yeah and the audio
change too
i absolutely love that detail
there's always one little that one
straggler there
i don't need to save i i'm feeling brave
nice dash melanie
see that really shows how you you don't
have to to stop to fight these enemies
if you really master that dash melee you
can just kind of
run and gun
it's a water puzzle i really love the
animation of the
water flowing from one area to the next
such a cool detail
now that the water levels change to have
access to other areas
and here is a map room
so interacting with these room will
grant me more visibility to the
area that i'm currently in um
so we sort of lightly touched on
this the narrative of this game which
occurs in the events
post metroid fusion and so that's why
samus's look looks different
but also to point out back to audrey's
point about
you know the game is about exploration
and action and so
this area uh map uh
upgrade allowed me to see more about the
map but
you can see that there's still a lot of
obscurity here
and so you need to explore
in order to uncover more of the area and
also
any secrets involved so yeah it's also
worth noting that
this series and this game is full of
really juicy lore
so whether you're a new or returning
metroid
fan if you've never played a metroid
game before it really gets you up to
speed with anything you need to know to
enjoy the story
and if you are a long-time metroid fan
you have a lot to look forward to
as sakamoto-san said this concludes the
story arc between samus and the metroids
so we've been waiting a long time for
this and it delivers
a little enemy that theresa just blew up
it's kind of like a item pinata gives
you a lot of
missiles yeah defeating enemies is a
definitely a boon because it grants you
replenishment for uh for energy and also
um missiles so definitely want to
defeat enemies for that i just didn't
expect the emmy to be right on top of me
when i
destroy the authors that little beeping
sound just i hear it in my nightmares
now
they always come up oh he's persistent
it's persistent
another interesting detail about this
game is normally in metroid games you
start at the surface of the planet and
you work your way deeper but in this
game you actually start deep within the
planet
and try and work your way to the surface
and so that
that yearning towards ascension really
adds to the tone
of this game as well
[Laughter]
i also love that you don't have to
necessarily wait for an enemy to attack
in order to counter in this game if you
keep an eye out you can actually
sometimes
counter before they if they start their
attack here's a throwback
so i have to use a missile in order to
destroy
that cover and then i'm able to access
that door just one missile though that's
good
oh of course
there you go i got it yeah
that's the other thing about the dash
melee is it uh
if you use that on an enemy you will get
i think a few more
extra items here's our first
upgrade the charge beam so
very iconic to the metroid series
so samus you know starts off without any
abilities and slowly
becomes more powerful and able to tackle
stronger foes but also be able to
uncover
or explore new areas that
we weren't able to before yeah and uh
suit upgrades are another classic part
of metroid gameplay that is alive and
well on this
game i love you can see if you keep an
eye on the background and stuff they're
all kind of cool statues and
architecture
that really uh piqued your curiosity
about
the lore of this world
i love that too using the charge beam to
make a charge we
spin attack and defeat some of those
enemies is
really handy oh that feels good
got some more life which is always a
plus for me
that
nice yeah look at all those items yeah
he's doing a great job of showing that
once you
you really get to know these abilities
and uh become adept at them
you start to feel like samus first
you're like
maybe not quite there but once you get
the hang of it you really start to feel
like a badass bounty hunter
yeah it's just so smooth it's like she's
parkouring through this
there's more great architecture but
we're not here to look at architecture
we're going to shoot things and explore
indoors so now we can't go through this
area because of the water
so we're not able to slide but we are
able to access this door that we weren't
to before
ah and here's another emmy door but
in order to not spoil any more surprises
here we're going to leave this as a
cliffhanger and
end our segment here all right well
that's all we've got
um on metroid dread for now thanks
teresa
audrey next up we've got some mario
superstar mario party superstars
to show you so stay tuned